hey guys it is Friday which means we've
got a top 5 for you but it's not just
any Friday it's Friday the 13th the
baker's dozen or Fridays oh that's
pretty good
but yeah in celebration of Friday the
13th we've got some spooky news me it's
not just news it's just regular news but
we do have this cool theremin sound
effect
[Music]
so okay we don't have any spooky news
but what we do have is pretty good story
from a three that's actually related to
this news story not sure if we've told
you this before but we're walking back
to our hotel and who did we spot taking
a photo in front of scene graffiti but
the famous French videogame designer
himself Michelle Anne self there he was
super nice I may have lost my [ __ ]
yeah I'm sure Luke told this story
anyway Michel Ancel was looking around a
secondhand shop recently and he saw a
statue of Raymond and he said maybe
after we're done with Beyond Good and
Evil 2 we'll go back to Raymond yeah he
was basically like don't let heroes die
which all I could think of was mercy I
do feel like this is gonna be a long way
down the track because we don't even
know when Beyond Good and Evil 2 is
gonna come out even that seems to be at
like tech demo stage at least from the
last time we saw it at e3 so to wait for
Raymond 4 off to that game comes out
it's probably gonna be a good handful of
years but the fact that he wants to make
it and it's gonna arrive it's fun yeah
and if you're interested in Beyond Good
and Evil 2 remember you can still sign
up for the space monkey program which is
their beta so got the website now it's
actually accessible now which it wasn't
during 8th right when we're all trying
to get in I actually need to do that my
PC brethren destiny - it's finally
coming to your platform although I'm
already playing on ps4 game at first
hopefully destiny 3 will come out at the
same time sure Ross
old platforms but we finally have a date
and a time
destiny 2 is gonna release on PC via
blizzards battlenet on October 24 at 10
a.m. Pt and here's a handy map so you
can check where it's gonna release in
your home town on frenzy wherever here
it is look at it look at that I'm gonna
leave it off for a little while I'll
talk about everyone's map so I'm really
bad at geography and I thought Seoul was
in China oh that's embarrassing yeah so
and that was like last year so anyway
the recommended specs have also been
released for what you will need to play
destiny - on your PC and they are just
go for it they have so you're gonna need
an Intel Core i5 2400 or 7400 and AMD
risen r5 1600 X you'll need an nvidia
geforce gtx 970 with 4 gigabytes of ram
or a gtx 1060 with 6 Sega bytes which
remind
I so really need to update my graphics
card my goodness that is high you can
also go for an AMD on 9 390 on top of
all that you'll need 8 gigabytes of RAM
and 68 gigabytes of HDD space so those
are some fairly mighty specs but that is
recommended settings not the minimum
settings so for a game like destiny you
can assume it's been adjusted pretty
well for low-end pcs as well so if you
want to check out what the minimum specs
are be sure to go to our story on site
one of my favorite games that I used to
play with my mates was live guru
HD I don't know if anyone's ever heard
of it but it's basically your
antropomorphic rabbit and your fight
[ __ ] it's like come foo
come hodgepodge it's so good it's like
one of the most mechanically satisfying
fighting games I've ever played
cool the developer will fly a games has
announced that they're the spiritual
successor to that game overgrowth is
leaving early access next week great so
that's pretty exciting on the 16th of
October overgrowth will be out of early
access and in that you again play as a
rabbit or sometimes a cat other
anthropomorphic creatures any just white
stuff and you punch it kick it this
games been in development for many many
many years since 2008 damn and it's been
going through alphas and betas but now
it looks like it's it's pretty much done
and I'm very excited to get in there and
have a good old play around oh my
goodness the internet is blowing up on
light boxes this past week every week
before it's uh it's been the top of
everything to a gap top of Reddit uh you
guys are kind of mad and you know what
run man we kind of feel I'm had to
because loot boxes I've always enjoyed
for their cosmetic stuff that you get
Rainbow six you get some silly charms Oh
what you get like some you get McCree
without a shirt on I think
earning them in overwatch is fun I think
because it's in a single-player game I
think it's absolutely ludicrous that I
would put extra dollars in in Australia
say for a game like shadow of war that's
gonna be a $90 game it's not even not he
does its ninety nine ninety five yeah
that's a it is ludicrous to me that
their stuff that is removed from the
game and not even at a DLC an expansion
pack level but at an item-by-item level
where they want you to get
all together and I say gamble because he
is our being has come out lately saying
they can't technically say that it's
gambling because it's not classified as
damnable there's the goods don't hold
any value and you can't sell them on so
therefore it's not gambling we can't
really talk to a lot of those games no
one's really come out and said anything
about those but someone who has is a
dice after the Star Wars Battlefront to
Vader they've said it in stock the stock
rate system hopefully won't disrupt the
balance of the game they're trying to
find a way to make that a balance drop
rate and stuff like that and they're
trying to make it so that our high-end
unlockables unlocked through game
milestones yeah however that seems like
a tricky balance to strike they also
said that obviously everyone who played
the beta saw the star club stuff and you
come across someone who had a cool you
know a load out the knew and that was
just completely through chance so people
said hey dice maybe
release some load where we don't have
star cards everyone has like a base set
of star cards and it's locked and
everyone's at an even playing field dice
have said that's a great idea we'll
bring it out but at the moment it's
still really weak yeah I miss I really
genuinely like it makes me feel old but
I missed the days where you just paid
for a game and it was your game and
there was no dumb platforms you had to
go through to access them there was no
like you know you might get a expansion
Heroes of Might and Magic would have an
expansion and that would be huge and
that would be a really big deal you
could download maps for free if you
wanted to but all this like it's nickel
and diming is what it is nickel and
diming for tiny little things and I
don't like what it's doing to the
industry I'm also getting upset with the
term microtransaction because it's
they're not microtransactions at all or
something like a loot box in Australia
that's 295 for loot box that's what a
microtransaction yeah you know I
wouldn't call me going to buy a coffee
in the morning of microtransaction
that's that's that's like a luxury it's
a luxury item and I feel like we can
expect that to get worse but that's just
what we think let us know what you think
down in that comment section the last
game I can remember cheating in was
grand theft auto san andreas and that
was because I wanted to get the jet pack
earlier I have learned not to
in the sims because I quite like my
rags-to-riches stories good but that is
a game where I would traditionally cheap
single player yay Salva shooting is
rampant in the online world as I'm sure
you all know and a particular game that
is for everything right now is fortnight
or epic has cracked down on the cheating
in fortnight especially in the battle
royale mode because I think they said
they've had 7 million downloads now
another battle Royales come out and
they've cracked down and banned
thousands of accounts and they've
actually taken it even further and
they've sued that well they're trying to
sue to to users oh so a complaint was
filed in the North Carolina federal
court and it's starting to cheaters
mister boom and mr. brass PA who are
accused of violating fortnight's Terms
of Service and the EU LA and infringing
on the copyright of the game by
modifying the game's code and that's
kind of a big thing yeah it's kind of a
big thing I mean there have always been
cheetahs and there's always been devs
trying to find a way to fight back
against them but I can't remember the
last case of the chain is actually being
sued well I know Blizzard do it a lot
stuff like Wow
in the complaint epic something
something ought really well they just
said nobody likes playing with cheetahs
and it's a hundred percent true there's
nothing less fun than being on a server
with someone who's clearly cheating yeah
this really does ruin the whole game
experience for everybody yeah don't
cheat in video games
cheat in single-player games I mean
that's that's fun that's great fun yeah
getting that jetpack early that is
everything we've got for you guys today
for our slightly angry Edition no
feelings about video games but do you
remember that you should leave us all of
your comments thoughts and feelings down
in that comment box and we will be back
hosting news for you Monday Tuesday and
Wednesday of next week but on Thursday
and Friday we're gonna have special
guest hosts covering for us so that'll
be exciting for you guys and if you're
in Australia
pax is around make sure you come to pax
there's gonna be a GameSpot theater this
year again we're gonna be there panels
walking around probably taking photos of
you in costumes it's not creepy I work
for a website I won't ever mustache this
time
to wrap it up see you guys next week he
news but what we do have is a pretty
good story from e3 we do we were on the
streets of Los Angeles walking around
welcome back to our hotel
who do we spot across the road taking a
photo in fairness in front of some group
let me start this whole segment again so
what